yeah it's very pertinent right now you
know it's in the newspapers very
significantly that some senior members
of government might be close within
their families to some level of tax
avoidance you know listen I I ain't a
lot of money okay and I I have money by
working and to be honest sometimes I
think it was ridiculous amount of money
I was paid for work but I paid 50 tax at
that time there was a temporary 50
income
tax threshold which I paid
um
and yet The Duke of Westminster inherits
eight billion pounds and pays nothing
you know so I'm probably in the top one
percent of earners that year officially
because that's taxable income but the
Duke of estimates the reason he pays
nothing is because that is not
classified as taxable income so what we
currently have is a tax system which is
very effective at taxing people like me
who come from poor backgrounds but
managed to do well and make some money
and extremely bad at taxing people like
the Duke of Westminster or like British
sonax's dear wife who don't work for
their money so you know
what we really have is a tax system
which is fair on poor people but doesn't
tax rich people at all